une voix devenue maintenant familière
même en france sur l'écran de cet
amphithéâtre volodymyr rennaise qui
comme à son habitude en t-shirt kaki
répond aux questions posées depuis paris
comment voyez vous aujourd'hui la
question de l'extension de l'otan à
l'ukraine
la russie qui a mis un point final
et
civilisé aujourd'hui veulent j être
protégée à dijon une trentaine
d'étudiants sont présents parmi eux une
poignée d'ukrainiens ils sont pour la
plupart loin de chez eux depuis un mois
et tous se posent la même question
comment en tant qu'étudiant d'ukrainiens
en france nous pouvons aider le plus
efficacement l'ukraine pour arrêter ce
guerre nous devons étudier et être très
fiers de notre pays et c'est pour ça que
monsieur alain ce que notre président a
dit que si on est dix étudiantes en
france nous devons être les bons élèves
les plus d'un élève que possible dans la
salle les étudiants français sont
également impressionné par le charisme
de ce président et surtout par la
résilience de leur camarade ukrainien
c'est le côté très humain que tu as ce
qui te ça le 10 juin que tu parles des
humains qui ont leurs parents qui sont
toujours en ukraine et de voir un peu la
tri station
passion qu'ils ont plus repas y sommes
touche moi personnellement mais faute de
temps seuls quelques étudiants de
sciences po paris auront pu poser des
questions à dijon loin d'être frustré
cette ukrainienne se réjouit de ces
échanges et aux capitaux tant qu'ils
étaient youth il se doit aussi de parler
aux jeunes parce que la jeunesse c'est
l'avenir du monde entier
je vais essayer de m'occuper de tout ce
qui reste après la guerre en ukraine et
nous devrons faire de notre mieux pour
reconstruire au total 1h10 de
visioconférence c'est court mais une
fois de plus le président et l'ins qui
aura marqué son auditoire
mais ces négociations ces pourparlers
pourvu que ça ne soit pas trop